we have some significant breaking news
to get to you right now that is just
coming into US exclusively here at NBC
News you remember that Virginia
six-year-old who shot his Elementary
School teacher we are just now learning
that he will not face charges sorry
can you warn them
dear little Sam you'll take the stage
kid can't even see over the [__] as a
six-year-old right that's crazy though
what I just said it out loud like well
how did it happen I think it was it was
I think it was his parents gun oh yeah
probably yeah from what I remember but
he shot his teachers so many times at
school yeah he took that [__] yeah that
[__] was not properly stored yeah put
one in the chamber this is the last day
Miss Natalie gonna [__] with me yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he rolled up you'll get the street yo
Nathan about that [__]
I think that's what happened
I think I really think so because it's
not an accident it cannot be an accident
so I just can't picture a young 16 year
old black yo Google gaga [__] and just
okay first obviously six years
but but close there's just something
about a tiny little person like
six-year-olds are tiny a firearm is a
lot to handle more normal
grown at him I'm going to say the fact
that he hit that's impressive no because
no they were close
even that close race not that for a
six-year-old that's impressive it's not
it's not that it's not listen I would be
really upset if my six year old shot
somebody if they shot someone successful
I'd be like that [__] got potential I'm
just saying we're raising ourselves a
shooter you're the problem Beyond him
being six the fact that this is even a
headline means a prosecutor really
considered it
where are you gonna send him to jail
exactly so where are you going to send
it am I unaware is there a jail for
[__] under 10 no I understand
you imagine the kid get charged but and
then for shooting his teacher like
you've been sentenced to like five years
of detention I don't know why I just
imagine getting a jury to send to
somebody and it'll be a jury of your
peers and there's a bunch of other
little kids
imagine a bunch of other kids that [__]
never gave me no dunkaroos [__] them
it's not even that this [__] 11
is like I just did five years in the pen
yeah yeah I just did five years inside
and I'm about to get some booty cheeks
again this is from an interview that you
will only see here on NBC News and our
team is getting with the city's
prosecutor just in the last really
couple of minutes or so the Newport News
Commonwealth Attorney who's overseeing
this case says they had some questions
about whether the six-year-old could
take the stand but that is still looking
at possible criminal charges for adults
now to recap this story and remember it
was headlines for gosh weeks here on
this outlet and others the six-year-old
shot his first grade teacher Abigail's
Werner in the hand and chest back in
January at richneck elementary school
you know he hit her twice
he hit her twice we got ourselves a
shooter
he said well you gonna write me up with
one hand [__]
wow that's a wild thing to do that means
that she probably had her hand in front
of her when he put out the gun yeah and
stop stop oh she spent two weeks in the
hospital a lawyer for the boy's family
and the law firm representings Werner
are declining comment as we speak I want
to bring in our NBC News legal analyst
Kristen Gibbons fed in okay so Kristen
um the the Prospect and again this is
just breaking here on nbcnews.com and
right here on NBC news now the prospect
that a six-year-old would take the stand
was described by this official as
problematic here
the fact that you had to get a legal
expert on to get their opinion on this
shows how [__] you are literally
everybody else on the planet looked at
this and went like
a six-year-old should not be on the
stand
unless I'm unaware what country are you
guys in where they charge six-year-old
this is only a thing that advocacy
happening in America in some countries
they marry off children so what the [__]
do I know
you're not marrying out these kids so
I'm gonna keep my mouth shut I apologize
to all my American brothers and sisters
yeah that [__] was kind of wild
but I own it yeah I appreciate you I
don't blindly [__] on y'all I do it
sometimes because I enjoy it but I mean
sometimes I Gotta Give it y'all y'all
don't marry off the kids you know you
let them shoot each other but you don't
marry him off keep in mind all
defendants whether a child or whether an
adult have a constitutional right to a
fair trial that involves having the
ability to assist in one's defense but
when you have a child who is six years
old typically Most states say under the
age of 10 they are unable to understand
the nature of the charges posed against
them and as a result they from a
competency standpoint have the it cannot
exercise their right to zealously
represent or assist in their defense and
so they aren't able to be charged just
from a constitutional perspective based
on their lack of confidence see due to
their chronological age the other piece
of this is that Howard Gwen this
Commonwealth's Attorney said that the
focus now
um if not the focus at least the
attention is turning to others meaning
adults meaning for example I would
imagine and he didn't specifically say
this he said any person or persons we
can believe proved Me On A Reasonable
Doubt committed a crime can use port
police chief Steve Drew has describe the
shooting as intentional I'm a Facebook
live video last month in which he said
the prosecutors would begin reviewing
the case Jew told viewers that it took
time for the tactics to interview the
children examine forensic evidence
zwinner 25 the teacher was seriously
wounded in the hand in her chest but
police said she still managed to safely
escort about 20 students out of the
classroom she was hospitalized for
nearly two weeks that's horrid
children we need to get out of here all
right
according to the lawyer for the person
who got shot a first grade teacher
that's the winner the boy had behavioral
issues in the pattern of troubling
interactions with school staff and other
students
a notice of intent to sue said that the
boy was given a one-day suspension for
breaking zwander's cell phone and
returned the next day with a nine
millimeter handgun that he used to shoot
his teacher in the classroom while she
sat at the reading table the antescano
was Winner's lawyer said at a news
conference in January that three
teachers went to the school
administrator about the boys behavior
and I always believe
to have had a gun on campus
wait they knew this has happened before
and the wake of the shooting the family
of the six-year-old boy said in a
statement that the weapon was secured in
the home and that they have always
committed to responsible gun ownership
and keeping Firearms out of the reach of
children [__] you lying
[__] you lying and secure what the [__]
does that mean in your drawer is it in
an unsafe is it behind a locket your kid
don't know the combination to
I refuse to believe that this little
[__] brought this gun to school
multiple times okay and you guys had it
secure that's cap and charges should be
laid against the parents the guy the gun
was not secured because any responsible
gun owner knows that once they secure
their guns they kids are not getting
access and the kids unless the kids have
been given access
so you know I'm one of those people who
I am pro-cut I think people should have
access especially in dangerous places
that's how I personally feel however it
also comes with a tremendous amount of
responsibility and people like this are
one of the problems that make it harder
for people to be responsible gun them
unfortunately there's just going to be a
lot of folks like this
so I understand the pushback that gun
rights activists get when examples like
these are made of a six-year-old having
access to a firearm that's crazy and the
parents really push on the fact that it
was properly secured
I don't know what it means for you but
properly secured for me and for anybody
here in Canada means that it has to be
locked
with a combination that nobody knows
you can even put it in a safe
with a combination that nobody if this
and it happened before so it's not that
there's access
that's major cap no no no that's that's
super cap you cannot that's that's
actually arrogance
that's arrogance you cannot come to me
and say that no it was properly secured
and this thing happened and damn I feel
like sometimes the parents
they kids can do no wrong and they can't
do no wrong either
if he was able
to access the thing
so easily and bring it
and the campus was advised that he did
it before no that's not secure that's
not the definition go look up the
definition of secure true go look up the
definition of secured you know there's
such thing as child proof
you know the little thing that they put
on on on on lighters right there's like
a little thing like for them to not to
it's not Chop roof we know that
kids can light up fires with that too
they claim it is just to make them feel
better but it's not you're storing that
gun however the hell you took the store
that gun was not chopproof no I think it
pretty much covers it Jesus [__]
Christ
dude somebody to get charged with a
school meal share parents somebody
six year old having access to guns
people not taking the precautions
necessary to protect those people that's
your job if people brought this
complaint to you and you didn't do
anything about it you got to hold that
out and and any kind of level of school
if teachers come to you and be like I
think that kid has a gun
and nothing is done
you're putting the kids at risk as well
yep at any level I come to you with the
climate that there is going on that's
going on in the states with the guns and
the schools and stuff like that teachers
go to the direction and say hey
they naked as a gun
and you do nothing hey the school's
getting charged nope the parents get in
charge everybody can get it the kid's
not gonna get charged because he's six
but jeez charge that little [__] too
give him detention for a few years
everybody can get it that's not even
grounded there's no word for that
detention
you shot at someone that's you're not
grounded you're the ground what you mean
I mean how much like how much times you
have to stay inside no like oh no if I
was six and I had five years of
detention every day oh that's punishment
I know which design is just that it's
just that's not the same that's prison
basically Jinx that's five-year-old
prison that's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but hey this really falls under adults
yeah let us know what you guys think in
the comments below